[Musique]
depuis le lancement sur le marché des
sérums contre le coc u19
les chiffres d'affaires de ceux qui les
fabriquent ne cessent de s'envoler
astrazeneca johnson johnson moderna et
bien sûr fraser bio ntech sont concernés
l'entreprise allemande associé à 20h
dans la conception du vaccin a prévu de
générer 15,9 milliards d'euros de
revenus sur l'ensemble de l'année 2021
c'est presque trois milliards de plus
que ce qui était prévu par l'entreprise
en mai dernier
d'après le patron de biotech
il n'est pas encore nécessaire d'adapter
la formule du vaccin en circulation pour
l'adapter aux variants il évoque
également les dose de rappel qui sont
selon lui la meilleure approche pour
gérer la situation
[Musique]
seloncourt scène un simple rappel avec
la formule de base serait tout à fait
suffisant pour renforcer l'immunité et
se protéger contre le coc vite 19
2,2 milliards de doses de ce vaccin
devrait être livré pour la seule année
2000 21
le duo fighter biotech a déjà signé des
contrats pour plus d'un milliard de
doses à fournir en 2022
d'ici la fin de l'année pfizer et
biotech espère atteindre une capacité
annuelle de production de trois
milliards de doses et 4 milliards pour
l'année prochaine avec un chiffre
d'affaires qui ne cesse de croître
la firme créée en 2008 pourrait ainsi
rentrer dans le club très fermé des 30
plus grandes sociétés biopharmaceutiques
en termes de revenus